une séance un peu particulière pour
cette soirée cinémathèque au studio ce
soir on projette devant une salle comble
des films tournés par des cinéastes
amateurs de la région
c'est le pwm patrimoine de cyclique qui
est chargé de faire vivre ce fonds
unique
[Musique]
cette tourangelle est venu apporter son
trésor des images tournées dans
l'immédiate après guerre par son père
alors qu'un cahier bien connu de la rue
de la tranchée à tour c'est les
souvenirs ça mais garder pour moi ben on
va d'abord il serait abîmé donc j'ai
préféré les déposer comme ça plutôt que
ce soit abîmée puis à +20 il en a fait
aussi sur des événements sont passés à
tour votre père est tourné en 16 c'est
ça on valorise ses films et les gens y
trouvent un intérêt dedans c'est des
choses qu'ils ont vécu ou tout
simplement cédé passionné c'est à dire
c'est des gens qui s'intéressent à
l'histoire locale et les films amateurs
sont porteurs de ça ils sont importants
dans seulement de la valeur familiale
des images enregistrées mais ang est
également là comment dire l'intérêt la
valeur documentaire dont ils sont
porteurs
est ce que vous savez ce qu'elle est ce
véhicule quand on le voit sur les images
c'est un véhicule tourangeau produit à
tour dès 1907
c'est la rolande pilote en fait alors là
on est rue nationale
là c'est lui le directeur charles
stisseurs qui ouvra le convoi avec
l'effort mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder dans l'arrière-plan
l'on s'aperçoit encore des stigmates
en fait de la gare qui sont encore bien
présents arrivé à issoudun dans les
locaux du pôle patrimoine de cyclique
les précieux film déposée par notre
tourangelle seront traités ici puis
archivée dans cette salle aux conditions
frigorifique
c'est là où se passe la consternation
physique des films les films que l'on
s'attaque ici ce sont principalement des
films réalisés par des cinéastes
amateurs depuis les débuts du cinéma
grosso modo depuis 1924 et jusqu'à nos
jours voilà que ça soit en pellicule ou
en vidéo ce sont des documents qui
viennent nous renseigner sur l'évolution
de la vie au xxème siècle dans notre
région la région centre val de loire
alors il ya des partis qui sont parfois
plus familial mais d'autres partis qui
sont à forte valeur documentaire et qui
ont un propos parfois inédits ou qui
sort
de ce qui a pu être filmée par les
autorités que ce soit les services des
armées que ce soit la télévision
voilà du cese a passé d'accord c'est
dans cette pièce que les précieux films
sont nettoyés indexés et numérisés dix
sept mille films sont assis
méthodiquement traité c'est un peu de la
mémoire de notre région qui est
aujourd'hui protéger et valoriser